you know building your relationship with
someone like p from qc what you know
he's he's somebody who has an executive
has
you know uh
done some special things him and coach k
uh what is some game or maybe some
advice that that you have gotten from
your friendship with would be a real
[ __ ] like
day one like
but when me and pete first linked up we
ain't discuss
signing or you know me beings or it
wasn't never about that [ __ ] let me
straighten my eyes like bro you a
hustler you remind me of me like i like
how you move i want to show you how to
turn this [ __ ] up and do this [ __ ] next
level i want to show you the business i
i think you should you need to really
learn
the business
it was never about him but signed a
contract but no game put no contract in
my face or email it to chanel it wasn't
never about none of that it was off top
like just a mutual respect like
and that was an honor to for a [ __ ]
like that to
look at me like a hustler i look at bro
like ultimate hustler you heard so for
somebody to see what i was doing on such
a small level compared to what he doing
and and it meant something you know and
it counted for something not only did it
show me i'm doing the right thing and i
can keep going but it showed me how to
conduct myself as a boss like when you
get to a certain level you it ain't
nothing wrong with reaching back when
you see other [ __ ] just like you you
are if you see yourself in another [ __ ]
and
you got to show people the business
you heard like i don't got the
impression from other people that
as long as you know the business you are
right
but he changed my mentality on that he
showed me that no the right thing to do
is to teach people the business then do
business with them
yeah they'll do business with them and
then teach them the business
teaching the business then do business
with them
so i kicking my young [ __ ] hyundai
he from grand rapids you heard like
he not he with ice directs we don't even
have a contract
because i'm teaching him
the business
and then that's then he got to decide if
he gonna if we're gonna rock if he's
gonna sign a
hey man that's not the because that's
not how this [ __ ] typically works but i
won't be able to fool him i don't wanna
i can't and you don't wanna if you wanna
be able to sleep in those foods you you
wanna sleep at night i wanna say it
ain't even just that i gotta i gotta
look my son and i and tell them i stood
tall in every situation i was silent
with everybody i ever encountered i
ain't [ __ ] nobody over i ain't
misguided nobody i mistreat nobody
everybody i ever
took took heed of what they said they
didn't mistreat me or misguide me
you heard so i wouldn't give out that
same energy and it's just it's just
gonna be solid like if every artist i
got with me
intelligent on the business side
and morally and they seeking the same
knowledge outside the muse that i see
that's it that's a powerful team mm-hmm
that's a strong fist now i feel like you
know qc is doing that i feel like god is
doing that you know he's definitely
doing that yeah see that guy and got it
don't talk about it just do that with it
he don't talk about it mm-hmm it's just
in his ass and they actions them to them
two [ __ ] that move actions
i mean you heard them [ __ ] ain't doing
on interviews talking about what they do
for artists their actions speak foreign